good morning Hank it's Friday I am
wearing a fox hat which is funny if
you've read Looking for Alaska I put
something in a book and then someone
made it real my whole life is like a
complicated Paper Towns cartographic
metaphor is a sentence that has never
been spoken before in human history
today's video comes to you in five parts
part one are zombies people - so Hank
the other day I was at
charlieissocoollike house not bragging
just stating a fact and I saw on his
famous wall of stuff to sign zombies are
people - so Hank one time many years ago
when I still lived in New York I was
hanging out with my friends Cassandra
Clare and Holly black and they got into
a knock-down drag-out fight on the topic
of weather trolls are people and ever
since seeing that sign on Charley's wall
have been thinking are zombies people
now Hank you're welcome to disagree with
me but it seems to me that the central
definition of zombie Ness is not slow
shuffling movements or even reanimation
or cannibalism it seems to me that the
central difference between zombies and
the rest of us is that zombies just walk
around doing whatever they have to do to
continue walking around what I'm
suggesting is the terrifying thought
that zombies may be people and in our
weaker moments we may in fact be zombies
but I don't know nerdfighters are
zombies people let us continue the
conversation in the comments part to the
guide to nerd fighting so Hank they're a
bunch of made of Awesome nerdfighters
who are trying to put together a book
that will be a guide to nerd fighting
with definitions of nerdfighter language
and stories from nerdfighteria artwork
and all kinds of stuff I think it's a
really cool idea to try to crowdsource
of book nerdfighters if you are
interested in helping guide to nerd
fighting comm link in the doobly-doo
part three Hank as you may have noticed
my library has been wreak a de logged oh
call me a nerd but I love a catalogued
library by the way my favorite recent
moment in vlog brother comment time
someone commented that guy looks like a
nerd and then a nerdfighter responded he
doesn't just look like a nerd to the
library whoa whoa whoa whoa okay I would
have been a stupid way to die
upstairs is pretty much the same my
foreign editions first editions of
fiction literary biography southern
studies art books some miniature chairs
in case we ever have miniature guests
more art books and then history then we
have fiction by dead people travel kids
books fiction by living people young
adult mystery novels memoir literary
criticism and of course our old friend
black Santa but the
downstairs Hank is brand new author
copies of Paper Towns boxing other
copies of Looking for Alaska desert
island books will Grayson Will Grayson
works of lexicography books about child
prodigies Mark Twain and abundance of
katherines more Mark Twain and also
books about death more young adult
fiction portrayals of puppy-sized
elephants in the dread pirate fireball
Wilson Roberts poetry and everything you
need to know about the goth scene in
your pants religion and books about
conjoined twins so there it is a miry
catalog home library I have to thank the
Yeti because she did almost all of this
knowing as she did that all I wanted for
my birthday was a reekado of home
library part for that thing that we've
been doing is actually a thing so a lot
of nerdfighters have noticed that in the
last few weeks we've been making these
voice-over videos where we go to a place
whether it's a bison range or Munich
okay unlike wheezy waiter who cowardly
refuses to acknowledge that explosion
Wednesday is a thing these videos that
we have been doing are a thing that the
beginning of the series of visual essays
we're calling thoughts from places you
can find out a little bit more about
thoughts from places on my web site link
in the doobly-doo
I'd love to point out my pants Hank and
speaking of pants part 5 important
developments in the field of your pants
Hank it is with considerable excitement
that today I announced that a
nerdfighter in the United Kingdom has
uncovered a children's book called the
sweaty Yeti in your pants this sweaty
Yeti oh my goodness oh I love my life I
love nerdfighteria Hank
best wishes I'll see you on Monday